do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from my Game of Thrones Season
eight episode 4 breakdown video now that
I have seen the episode a couple times I
want to sit down and get my thoughts on
what happened I am noticing there are a
lot of fans that do not like the new
episode again but I actually enjoyed
this one there were some scenes that I
did not really care for but overall I
thought it was an interesting episode I
really liked some of the new things they
are setting up for the final two
episodes but maybe that's me
I guess I will find out as soon as all
of you start commenting on the video
well let's start off by talking about
Daenerys Targaryen
Dany really got her ass kicked in this
episode in a number of different ways
first she had to say her final farewells
to Sir Jorah Mormont someone that has
been there since the very first episode
of the show as you all know they had
their ups and downs over the years but
Jorah became one of the very few
characters that I think Daenerys knew
she could trust now that he's gone you
could see that Dany was already starting
to feel the impact of his loss that was
shown in one of the very next scenes
when everyone was celebrating their
victory over the army of the Dead
Daenerys was surrounded by everyone that
was having fun but she had no one by her
side she might as well have been sitting
in the room all by herself because it
was almost as if she wasn't even there
the Lannisters were back together so now
they're off drinking and having fun
John is hanging out with his close
friends so he's drinking and having fun
even Danny's other close friend
missandei is now spending most of her
time with someone else other than Varys
who she cannot trust which is something
I have said Danny had no one in that
moment this is something that Varys
noticed almost immediately him and Danny
could see how everyone was acting around
John now although Danny was out there on
her dragon just as much as John was they
still see John as their leader no matter
how much Dany helps they will always see
her as an outsider
Daenerys knows if they ever find out
John is the rightful heir to the Iron
Throne everyone well line up the stand
beside him before they would continue to
stand beside
we saw them talk about this when they
were alone together now it's no secret
I'm a big fan of Jon Snow I always have
been and I probably always will be but I
felt really bad for Daenerys after this
episode was over she came to Winterfell
ready to sacrifice every single thing
that she had in order to help stop the
army of the dead she did not have to do
this now it would have been really dumb
for her not to but she could have went
for the Iron Throne like she wanted then
she could have tried to fight the army
of the Dead when they eventually killed
everyone at Winterfell then came down to
King's Landing
Danny had that choice but thankfully she
made the right one not only did she
bring her entire force but she also
fought the army of the Dead herself
it's not like she was hiding down in the
crypts of Winterfell during the entire
battle but Sansa to still not like her
even though Dany is the main reason
songs is even still alive sanso does not
want to see her sitting on the Iron
Throne I have to be honest I did not
like the way sunzha was acting in this
episode I did not mind when Sansa was
speaking up for the north but I think
she has taken things too far this time
now I obviously understand why she would
act like that at first
Sansa does not know Danny and based on
the Starks and the Targaryen history
together
Sansa did have a reason to be cautious
however I think Dany has now shown that
she can be trusted it's not like she's
asking them to forgive her father for
everything he had done Danny just
doesn't want everyone to judge her for
her father's crimes what sahn's is doing
behind Danny's back could get her killed
songs are also lied right to John's face
out in the godswood not even five
minutes go by and Sansa already starts
to tell other characters the truth about
John this is something grey area and I
talked about well over a year ago on my
channel when we collaborated together we
said if anyone will cause issues between
John and Danny it will absolutely be
songs of stark and you can already see
how things are about to unfold Daenerys
will eventually lose everything that she
has like I said Jorah Mormont is already
gone
my Sande is now dead most of our
soldiers are dead and now she only has
one dragon remaining even if Danny is
somehow able to defeat Cersei Lannister
and take King's Landing it will cost or
every single thing that she has now that
all these other characters are starting
to find out John has the rightful claim
they are already thinking of ways to
sir Danny does not sit on the Iron
Throne by the end even if John doesn't
want it it really won't matter think
about it like this
who does Danny have on her side to make
sure she can keep the Iron Throne if she
wins the battle for King's Landing she
has her dragon she has her very small
force of soldiers and she has tyrion and
varys well most of her soldiers well die
in King's Landing there is also a very
good chance that Danny loses her other
Dragon Cersei and Khyber now have dozens
and dozens of ballistas aiming at the
sky now they only have to aim it at one
dragon which means Danny will have to
avoid getting hit by every single shot
that's fired that's very hard to do when
you have that many firing at you at the
same time Qyburn must have done
something extra to these new ballistas
because they went right through ragel
like a hot knife through butter as
ridiculous as that scene may have been I
knew it would happen they needed to take
away another one in Danny's dragons just
so they can make the battle interesting
I would have rather seen regel die
fighting then die like this I cannot
even begin to tell you how angry I was
when I saw reg all fall into the water
like he did I would love it if Danny was
somehow able to get some armor made for
drug on before she goes into battle next
episode so if Danny ends up losing the
rest of her soldiers and her other
dragon all she would really have left on
her side is tyrion and varys well as you
can see in the episode they're not about
to be on her side for very long
especially when she starts to burn
King's Landing down to nothing but ash
we have already seen what Varys is ready
to do he's already thinking about having
Danny murdered now most of you should
have already seen this coming I have
been predicting this in my videos for
quite some time they really started to
foreshadow this betrayal during season 6
should I tell you what the voice said
should I tell you the name of the one
who spoke
[Music]
we serve the same queen if you are her
true friend you have nothing to fear
from me I recently made a video where I
said I think Varys and Tyrion will
betray Daenerys together mostly because
these characters are always together and
they have been this way ever since they
left King's Landing back in season four
Varys is already trying to convince
Tyrion that Dany is not the right one to
stand behind sooner or later both of
them will turn their backs on Danny this
will most likely lead to them getting
killed we already know Varys is meant to
die by the end of the season Melisandre
and can Varro foreshadowed this if you
don't mind my saying I don't think you
should return to West dress I'm not sure
you'd be safe here
I will return their Spyder one last time
your lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you so this is how I
think all of this is about to unfold
like I said before Danny will have no
choice but to attack King's Landing
they will make her out to look like the
monster which most of us know is not the
truth King's Landing will get caught on
fire then Danny's story will ultimately
end in a tragedy she will lose
everything she has in order to take back
to the Iron Throne and as soon as she
does that she will end up dying for it
as well what makes this even worse is
the fact that Jon doesn't even want the
Iron Throne and neither of them will sit
on the Iron Throne by the end varus and
Tyrion will both be executed for their
treason Varys already committed this but
Tyrion will soon follow in his footsteps
we also know that Jaime Lannister Arya
Stark and Sandor Clegane are on their
way down here as well this is how they
will end up getting to Cersei Lannister
I made some videos about this already
but I think they will find a secret way
to get into the red key Jaime will then
kill Cersei Sandor will kill his brother
and I'm not exactly sure about Arya
Stark maybe she ends up helping the
Hound kill his brother in some way they
did talk about this before a very long
time ago the names of every [ __ ]
person in Westeros hates us good the
thing is Annie to keep a person going
better than most
we come across my brother maybe we can
both cross the name off a list this was
foreshadowed several times in the last
episode Sandor Clegane will not be able
to rest until he knows his brother is
dead we will absolutely get cleganebowl
next episode
now Jamie did make it sound like he
needed to be with Cersei but I think he
will be the one to kill her I'm thinking
that maybe he said all of that to
Brienne just to make sure that she did
not try to follow him I'm not exactly
sure but there is no way Jaime falls
back into the same trap his character
has come too far to do that again I also
think there is a reason why Cersei
talked about the baby in front of your
own Greyjoy that has to be setting up
something for later now you're on should
know that baby is not his Cersei just
told him about it in that episode but
when Tyrion shows up to talk to Cersei
in front of the gate he somehow knows
about the baby already
how would Tyrion know that Cersei is
pregnant when you're on just found out
himself I think when Jaime shows up to
kill Cersei he will most likely say
something - you're on that is of course
if he has the chance
Jaime could be the one to kill you're on
but I could also see him getting killed
by Danny's dragon either way they will
all end up dead by the end of the battle
now you know who I think ends up what
the most power in the end songs a stark
since Cersei and most likely Dany will
be dead and Jon Snow is out of the way
Sansa will be the last one standing who
somehow ends up holding most of the
cards that's what I think eventually
happens by the end
shawne's is staying in Winterfell during
the battle so she will most likely still
be alive at the end of the story arias
said she's never going back to
Winterfell which was kind of actually
sad to hear or say that but I totally
understand it as we all know Arya is
like Nymeria after all she is meant to
be out in the wild I'm heading north
girl
back to Winterfell I'm finally going
home come with me
[Music]
now I don't know if we ever need to see
Gendry again unless he goes down to
King's Landing to fight I doubt we will
see him there he was legitimized like I
thought he would be
Annie was given storms end now that him
and Arya have went their separate ways
Gendry story might be done I really
don't see what else they could have him
do Sam and Gilly story is basically done
it did seem like John and Sam said their
final farewells to each other and it
wasn't very clear where Sam and Gilly
would go next but they might end up back
at Sam's childhood home to raise their
baby together
now one conversation that I did find
very interesting was when John said
goodbye to tormund Giantsbane I could
not help but get the sense that John
somehow ends up back in the far north
everything that was said in that
conversation felt like it was
foreshadowing how John's story would end
the only thing is I'm not exactly sure
where John would go I don't really see
him living way out beyond the wall with
all the wildlings but I really can't see
him going back to Castle black either it
seems like the Nights Watch no longer
serves a purpose the wildlings have been
accepted into the Seven Kingdoms and as
far as we know the night King and the
army of the Dead are gone forever
so why would they still need the wall in
the Nights Watch not to mention the wall
has been collapsed that he's to watch by
the sea so unless someone knows how to
fix that everything north of the wall
can still get south anyway who knows
maybe John does not go back in that
direction but it definitely felt like
their conversation was setting something
up for later I did not like the last
scene John and go sad together either so
hopefully he does see him again in the
end it would be really nice if John and
ghosts were able to get at least one
meaningful scene together I don't think
that's asking for much
this episode was another sad reminder of
how close we are to the end when we saw
John saying his goodbyes to everyone I
could not help but think this might be
the last time we ever see some of these
characters together again now I know
this season has a lot of fans upset
which I do understand but knowing things
are almost over does make me kind of
emotional this show has made such a big
impact on my life
ever since I started making videos what
just several years ago now I have
thought about the story in these
characters every single day it's
definitely going to be hard to say
goodbye to these characters once the
final episode does end anyways let me
know your thoughts on the episode how do
you
think all these different storylines
will end I want to thank everyone for
watching another video and I also want
to thank all of you for supporting the
channel I hope you have a great day I'll
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]